if I can get excuses out of people I can
take the things away from them that
paralyze them that caused them to
hesitate and pause so then I said what
are the biggest excuses that we deal
with well fear is a big one I'm scared
to do it I'm scared to do it
but what we're scared of means that
people have already done I'm not talking
about standing on the edge of a cliff
obviously but you know in business and
risk I mean these aren't new things fear
other people who've done this fear is BS
in my view and then I look at scarcity
well I don't have the money well tell
that to Steven jobs in his garage
scarcity and then I love to excuse
circumstance well you know it's a
recession I can't make money was the big
one years ago people got rich during the
recession a lot of people did so during
our pandemic look at house hand
sanitizer companies and mass companies
and look at how these industries
somebody's making money during all of
these things
[Music]
one of the things I've heard you say is
that fixing bars is easy fixing people
is hard
did you realize going into it how much
of it was just gonna be dealing with
like the psychology of people because
usually that seems to be what you're
fixing you go in and fix the bar after
but you really fixing the people first
and that was sort of an evolution
honestly because when I started this I
was a consultant and I was a very well
known consultant so I had very well
known clients right so my clients are
people like Marriott corporation and how
are they in Zink and Fridays and you
know companies like that so I never knew
this level of failure even exists today
I never saw anything like this before in
my life
so when I said to the network I want you
guys find me real failures I don't want
this easy let's make this real I ever
comprehended this I mean to think that
somebody's 50 years old they half a
million dollars in debt living in their
parents basement with their child
losing $30,000 a month out of money you
know no credit and they're still going
it's it's remarkable and you know most
of these people have two to three weeks
left and then they're done anyway so it
really is the last chance for them so I
know I could do the whole hour on bar
rescue with you but how much of the
interactions like I get you're being
real and you just learn from them do you
sense it's always this thing where you
see people suddenly doing these crazy
things right before we started I said I
was watching one yesterday doing cardio
where this there's this woman who's an
owner of a bar she's probably in her
mid-50s she's got you know she's got big
boobs she has people doing shots you
know offer a rack like like some of it
seems like it's like too crazy to be
real and yet I suspect it probably isn't
well it no it's completely real
everything is completely real there are
no actors there's no scripts there's no
reshoots it is completely real and when
I looked at her and I hope I could say
this on this podcast when I looked at
her and said I can help your sagging
business I don't know if I can help your
saggy boobs I know I said that to her
for a reason I wanted to embarrass her
and you know when I started bar rescue
day
was all about dirty bars and you know
remodels and you know several episodes
into it I realized how flawed these
owners were to be in those situations
and if I didn't change them I couldn't
change anything and it was about a
hundred and twenty episodes in believe
it or not I was in Detroit Michigan with
a female owner of a bar I think I named
the proving grounds and I looked at and
I said why are you failing and Dave she
looked at me in the eyes and said to me
I am failing because of the euro in
Greece now this was in suburban Detroit
Michigan and at that moment I realized
that a hundred and twenty times earlier
I had asked these business owners why
are they failing and never once day
within anyone ever looked at me and said
I'm failing because of me John not once
so I realized wait a minute if she goes
home and blames the Euro on her failure
she is no reason to change they look in
the mirror in the morning and she'll say
that damn euro taking me down but if she
looked in the mirror and said I'm
failing because of me
she wouldn't like that she would change
that hit me a couple of years ago or
three years ago and I realized that
excuses are the common denominator of
failure and then I thought to myself a
little farther what is an excuse in
excuses the reconciliation of a mistake
you do you did something I shouldn't
have you didn't do something you should
have or you screwed up or you wouldn't
need the excuse so an excuse is your way
of making yourself feel good about your
own failure it's the most paralyzing
thing in business as an excuse so when I
realize that I said to myself wow I
think I found a common denominator of
failure if I can get excuses out of
people I can take the things away from
them that paralyze them that caused them
to hesitate and pause so then I said
what are the biggest excuses that we
deal with well fear is a big one I'm
scared to do it I'm scared to do it
but what we're scared of means that
people have already done I'm not talking
about standing on the edge of a cliff
obviously there but you know in business
and risk I mean these aren't new things
fear other people who've done this fear
is BS in my view and then I look at
scarcity well I don't have the money
well tell that to Stephen jobs in
history
scarcity and then I love the excuse
circumstance well you know it's a
recession I can't make money was the big
one years ago people got rich during the
recession a lot of people did so during
our pandemic look at house hand
sanitizer companies and mass companies
and look at how these industries
somebody's making money during all of
these things and then I looked at you
know the other excuses you know and and
I came up and I realized that if I can
take these excuses out of people's lives
I can stop what paralyzes them so that
all happened in that Detroit episode and
from that I wrote the book don't BS
yourself cut excuses that are holding
you back which made it to the New York
Times bestseller list and I'm very very
proud of that book because when you
finish it excuses won't work for you
anymore
now your self accountable now when you
look in the mirror in the morning you
will blame yourself and you should yeah
well and that's what seems to be the
consistent consistent message throughout
the shows that the owner usually is
making all sorts of excuses for all
sorts of things and if you can fix that
guy or that girl then then the rest of
the pieces do fall into place do you
guys ever do look backs where you're
trying to figure out well who who
actually succeeded after this or who who
the next day after they got their brand
new beautiful bar just screwed up the
whole thing because I'm sure that
happens to ya there's a website called
bar rescue updates it's an independent
website we have nothing to do with it it
travels on a success of bar rescue
and of course for now everybody's closed
but pre-pandemic we were tracking at
about 68 to 70 percent success factor
now I don't know what their definition
of success was they haven't it's open
three years later it to you I don't know
but I know that they had us tracking at
about it's 68 percent it was also a
newspaper article that rated to two
other restaurant conversions shows and I
won't mention the shows or the hosts but
there's three of us that tend to claim
this space my show rent about a 68
percent success factor the other two are
in the 20s so I'm very I'm very pleased
with what we do I go at it as a
consultant and the cameras are along for
the trip I don't go at it as a TV host
then a consulting is along for the trip
and I think that's why we're successful
alright cool so as I said I I love the
show so I
could talk about it for an hour but I do
want to talk question I didn't ask you a
question yes we did 20 back to the bar
episodes also ruie went back and looked
them and I think those are on a
paramount website and those were sort of
fun to go okay I'm gonna have to check
those out so you mentioned a little bit
about your career before all this and
consulting and all that when I was doing
a little research this morning I saw
that you used to work at the Troubadour
in West Hollywood I used to live about a
block from there I've been to a bunch a
bunch of different events over there can
you tell me a little bit about how you
got into food service the early
beginnings of your career where your
sort of ethos around personal
responsibility and and the rest of it
came from well when I was young that
play I was a very serious musician I
took drum lessons to nine years it was
very good I still have a drum set
upstairs in my office uh I was very good
and so I wanted to be a musician but my
family and there's another side of me
that wanted to be going to business so
make a long story short I went to
University of Denver and majored in
political science and minored in
cultural anthropology which I love the
study of primates and what makes us
think and understanding our primal
behaviors and such and I started
attending Bar in college and one thing
led to another and to chase my music
career and now that I had a bartending
skill I went to Los Angeles got an
apartment to the Oakwood apartments in
Studio City back then which had quite a
social hot tub scene back in those days
I got a job in The Troubadour cos it
connected bartending and music for me
and then evolved to be manager of the
Troubadour and also worked in Barney's
Beanery down the street and managed
Barney's oh yeah yeah well there yeah
sure so uh that was my real beginnings
when I took over the Troubadour we had
about 8 inches of water on the floor in
the kitchen it was flooded and we had no
money and Doug West in the owner may he
rest in peace back then had recreational
drug habits and I would close the
Troubadour and I'd put $800 or whatever
in a for safe and I'd have to come back
at 8:30 in the morning to get that $800
out to pay for the liquor cuz everything
was co dicus we had no credit and I'd
come in the morning and the money would
be gone cuz Doug took it for drugs the
night before
so I had to run this business in a most
unfavorable of ways I had no money he
kept taking the money I started taking
it home at night so he couldn't get it
in the morning I had a flood in the
kitchen that we didn't have the money to
fix
I got pallets wooden pallets we threw
him on the kitchen floor so he could
walk over the water rather than and have
dough and that's how we opened a
troubadour and I coordinated something
called the 25th anniversary of the
troubadour and we got everybody from
George Carlin to Linda Ronstadt all of
them to come back during that month and
we made the money and stabilized
operations if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about lifestyles instead of non-stop
yelling check out our lifestyle playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlist they're both right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell